[موسيقى]
هو الذي يقذف مطلقا حيواناته المنويه على
عاتقها فهي التي ستحمل لاحقا عبء تفادي
الحمل في حال لم يكن مرغوبا لان بطنه لا
ينتفخ ولان لا رحم في احشائه ولانه لا
يحمل تسعه اشهر كانت الحبه السحريه من
نصيبها ورغم كل عوارضها الجانبيه المقيته
كانت حبوب منع الحمل في مرحله ما رمزا
للحريه الجنسيه فقيل انها لتحرير النساء
لكنها حملتهن وحدهن المسؤوليه وبقي الرجال
في عالم منع الحمل مع عواقيهم ذكري بمختلف
الوانه واحجامه ونكهته
فلماذا لم تكن للرجال حبتهم السحريه كما
النساء ماذا عن وسائل منع الحمل الذكريه
الاخرى هل هي فعاله اصلا ولماذا لا يلجا
اليها الا قله قليله منهم هل هو خوف
الرجال من فقدان فحولتهم ام تمسكهم بدورهم
البدائي كمخاصمين ولماذا لا يمر طريق
تنظيم النسل الا على اجساد النساء وعلى
حساب صحتهن في فلك الممنوع
وسائل منع الحمل ليست مستجده على البشريه
اذ نجد اثرا لها عند المصريين القدماء
والاغريق مثلا التقليديه منها تشمل اخراج
القضيب من المهبل قبل القذف او الامتناع
عن العلاج المهبلي ايام الخصوبه هناك ايضا
الواقي الذكري الذي ظهر باشكال مختلفه قبل
عده قرون وانتشر بنسخته الحديثه في سنوات
الثلاثينيات وفي القرن العشرين ظهرت وسائل
اخرى زادت من ثقل المسؤوليه على النساء
فحسب الامم المتحده 67% من وسائل منع
الحمل تبقى نسائيه من ابرزها الحبوب
اليوميه حقن الاستروجين والبروجسترون
الادوات التي تزرع تحت الجلد في اعلى
الذراع وتلك التي توضع داخل المهبل
كاللولب والحلقات المرنه والواقي الانثوي
يضاف ذلك الى التعقيم الدائم عبر ربط او
قطع قناتي لمنع وصول البويضات الى الرحم
اغلب هذه الوسائل لها اثار جانبيه منها
النزف المؤقت الغثيان الصداع الام الثدي
وارتفاع ضغط الدم ومن مخاطرها ايضا جلطات
ونوب القلبيه وامراض الكبد والاكتئاب
بالنسبه الى الرجال لم يتم تسويق اقراص
منع حمل بعد لكن هناك حقن التسترتيرون
الدوريه التي توقف انتاج الحيوانات
المنويه في السائل المنوي وتمكن استعاده
الخصوبه عبر التوقف عن اخذ الحقن يلجا بعض
الرجال ايضا الى الاساليب الحراريه وهي
حلقه مطاطيه او سروال يحتوي على حلقه يتم
تمريرها حول القضيب والصفن المغلف
للخصيتين فترتفعان الى اعلى ما يزيد درجه
حرارتهما ويوقف انتاج الحيوانات المنويه
هناك ايضا التعقيم عبر سد او قطع الازهرين
وهما القناتان اللتان تنقلان الحيوانات
المنويه نحو القضيب هذا لا يعني توقف
انتاج السائل المنوي لكنه يكون خاليا من
الحيوانات المنويه التراجع عن هذه العمليه
يبقى مكلفا وليس مضمونا بشكل كامل ما قد
يتسبب بعقم نهائي وفق مراجع صحيه عده
[موسيقى]
وسائل منع الحمل اذا للرجال في فلك
الممنوع البدايه من تونس العاصمه مع
الاستاذ في الفلسفه والباحث في دراسات
الجندر حازم الشيخاوي اهلا بك سيدي اليوم
عندما يقال منع حمل تتداخل الخرافه
بالمعلومات الخاطئه والنتيجه ان الجميع
يفكر بالمراه لكن للرجال وسائل من حمل غير
الواقي الذكري انت كرجل من مجتمع عربي هل
تعتبر نفسك جاهزا لتجريب وسائل منع الحمل
الذكريه المتوفره
شكرا وشكرا للاستضافه الحقيقه السؤال صعب
ولكنه يحتوي على مستويات اخرى يجب الاجابه
عليها قبل ذلك واولا هل ان هذه الادويه
اليوم التي تعطي للرجال والنساء هي كفيله
بان تحافظ على صحتنا وهل هي داخل منطق
حمايه وداخل المنطق وقايه ام هي تعكس رؤيه
اجتماعيه ما وهيمنه ما
في الحقيقه انا لا امانع اذا ما كانت هذه
الوسائل هي وسائل للوقايه ولا الحمايه
بطبيعه الحال لكن سنرتطم في المجتمع
العربي وفي كل المجتمعات على اختلاف
تمثلاتنا وعلى اختلاف رؤيتنا لهذه المسائل
لانها مجتمعات تطغى عليها الرؤيه الذكوريه
وتظهر عليها الرؤيه الابويه التي تعتبر ان
السجين الاول لهذه المواد هي اجساد النساء
وذلك ليس بغريب لان التطور الطبي على مر
السنوات تقريبا من خمسينات القرن الماضي
الى حد هذه اليوم قام بابتكار عديد ادوات
منع الحمل التي تمارس على النساء لكن لم
نجد الا مؤخرا
ابتكار تاخرت تاخرت جدا على الرغم من وجود
بعض التجارب منذ سنوات السبعينات تقريبا
لكن اليوم هذه الفكره ما زالت جديده ولا
اعتقد ان المجتمعات العربيه ستقبل بها
نظرا لانها مجتمعات كما قلت هي مجتمعات
ابويه ومجتمعات محافظه ومجتمعات لرؤيتها
الخاصه لتماثلات اجساد الرجال والنساء
اسمح لي ان ننتقل بعد قليل الى الحديث عن
بعض الخصائص المجتمعات العربيه في هذا
الاطار ولكن قبل ذلك
ساسال هنا في الاستوديو في باريس سارحب
بالمتخصص في الطب الجنسي دكتور جلباب ابو
جوده اهلا بك دكتور من خلال الممارستك
لمهنه الطب الجنسي هل انت تمارسون في
فرنسا هذه المهنه هل بات ياتيك عدد اكبر
من الرجال الذين يسالون عن وسائل منع
الحمل او يتحدثون بوسائل منع حمل لهم وليس
لشركتهن ام ان المساله لا تزال نسائيه
بامتياز بعد المساله نسائيه
بس في اكثر واكثر رجال
بيجوا بيسالوا
لطريقه منع الحمل لالهن
صار لها خمس ست سنين بلشت عند الرجال
بفرنسا بامريكا مثلا من وقت ما صار في
حمله
منعوا حبوب الحمل للنساء وتوقيف الحمل صار
في كتير طلب من الرجال تيعملوا طريقه لمنع
الحمل عند الرجال
بعد القصه كتير خفيفه عند الرجال بس عم
تتطور اكثر واكثر برايك لماذا تاخر هذا
الامر في صعوبات طبيه صعوبات نفسيه
وصعوبات اجتماعيه صعوبات الطبيه هي عند
الرجال
ساعه لما نلاقي طريقه تنوقف الحمل عند
الرجال فبركه الخلايا كل يوم 24 ساعه 24
ساعه عند النساء نعرف انه في سيك بنعرف
انه بالنها
بالشهر لازم نقطع هالبو عند الرجال كل
دقيقه كل ساعه منفبرك خلايا يعني لازم
تكون طريقك صح لازم نكون طريقه كامله مشان
هيك مثلا كل طرق منع الحمل اللي سمعنا عنك
كانت بابر او حبوب او بجلب كريم بتنحط على
الجلده عند الرجال بدها ثلاث اربع اشهر
تعطي مفعول وبس يوقف بده بين ثلاثه اشهر
وسته اشهر تترجع الخلايا صعب في صعوبه
طبيه عم بتصعبها تتكون الطريقه المستعمله
كتير عند الرجال اذهب الى بيروت مع
الصحفيه والناشطه النسويه صبا السكريه
اهلا بك يا صبا صبا انت كتبتي عن وسائل
منع الحمل للرجال وقابلتي عددا منهم خلال
اعدادك لهذا التقرير كيف كانت ردود الفعل
وكيف تقيمين هذا الردود خاصه ان الدكتور
جلباب تحدث منذ قليل عن اسباب طبيه وليس
فقط ايضا عن اسباب اجتماعيه هلا حدثتينا
عن هذا الشق لو سمحتي
انا في التقرير التي الذي اجريته الشهر
الماضي عن حبوب المنع منع الحمل للرجال
كان هناك مقابلات مع تقريبا خمس او ست
رجال في هذا المجال هلا المواضيع كانت
مختلفه الاراء كانت مختلفه ولكن انا يعني
حسب ما شاهدت انه كان في عدم تقبل للفكره
بالبدايه بالبدايه اصلا سالوني انه كيف
يعني ما هي حبوب المنع منع الحمل للرجال
كيف
انها الحمل بشكل دائم او لانها غير موجوده
حتى الان يعني هذه الحبوب هي في قيد
التطوير يعني هي قيد اتفضلي
مزبوط هناك يعني هي هي لانه نسبه للدراسه
التي اجريت مؤخرا حول حبوب منع الحمل
للرجال اللا هرمونيه التي لا تؤثر على
الهرمونات عند الرجل ولكن الاراء معظم
الاراء كانت لا كان فيها رفض كان فيها رفض
لشيء جديد كان فيها رفض لشيء غريب على
المجتمع ولا يعتبر بالنسبه لهم شيء عادي
لانه يؤثر على دور كذكور بالمجتمع يعني
كانت معظم الاراء البعض الاخر قالوا انه
لا يمكن ان نستعمل حبوب منع الحمل للرجال
ولكن الفكره الاساسيه هي بعدم معرفه ما هي
اثاره الجانبيه ما هي يعني ما هو ما هي
مجهوله نسبه فعالياتها بشكل
ما بالنسبه الى العامه خاصه في ربما في
الدول العربيه ومن هنا ساسال
نعم ساسال من القاهره
استشاري المناعه والتغذيه العلاجيه
والامراض المزمنه وخريج الازهر في
الدراسات الاسلاميه دكتور
جوده محمد عواد اهلا بك دكتور جوده انت
ربما لا تؤيد اللجوء الرجال الى وسائل منع
حمل جذريه مثل سروال الحراري او حقن
تسوستيرون او التعقيم لماذا
اولا مساله تعقيم الرجال او مساله منع
الحمل هذه المساله ممنوعه شرعا واي انسان
يؤمن بها يعني خرج عن الدائره الايمانيه
ليه لانه المطلوب مننا ان نحافظ على النسل
ويكفي ان نستعرض مثلا تجربه اليابان حيث
33 مدرسه ابتدائيه اغلقت وفي بعض دول
اوروبا وفي بعض ولايات امريكا تاثر تاثرت
المدارس كذلك وتاثرت الاجيال القادمه معنى
تاثر الاجيال القادمه اي اننا في استعمال
خاطئ لمساله منع الحمل لكن الدول اليوم
تقوم بتنظيم الاسره يعني لديها وزارات
للاسره لتنظيم الاسره ومن اصول تنظيم
الاسعار هو وسائل وسائل منع الحمل اليوم
نناقش وسائل
يعني اليوم
النساء
المستهدفات في وسائل المنع الحمل لماذا
عندما نتحدث عن الرجال ان نقول
يجب ان نقول اولا اننا مع مصطلح تنظيم
الحمل وليس منع الحمل كلمه منع الحمل دي
تتمسح من القاموس خالص ما فيش حاجه
اسمها الحمل لماذا
لماذا لان اصل الزواج واصل الكيان البشري
واصل وجود الانسان على الارض هو التناسل
هو مش موجود هنا علشان ياتي ليتمتع شهوه
فقط ويستمتع لا لا هو مش مطلوب منه هذا هو
جاي لعماره الارض وجاي لاستخراج كنوز
الارض ولا يتم هذا الا بالتكاثر فقط نحن
مع التنظيم بمعنى ان يكون في البصره بين
الاول لسنا في سنه نقاش الراي الديني ولكن
نحن نريد ان نفهم لماذا اليوم يقبل ان
يعني على المراه او يطلب من المراه حين
يكون ما تحدثت عنه من تنظيم الاسره امر
واقع يطلب منها هي ان تاخذ وسائل منع
الحمل وهذا اسمها العلمي
ويطلب من الرجل او عندما ياتي دور الرجل
يقول لا الرجل يعني ليس في هذا الصدد
لماذا
ساحكي ساحكي لك تجارب كثيره المراه عندها
بويضه هذه البويضه تفرز من المبيض ثم
تنتقل عبر قناه المبيض الى الرحم وتنتظر
الاخصاب هذه بويضه كل شهر اذا لم تخسب
البويضه فان جدار الرحم يطردها فيما يسمى
بالدوره الشهريه اذا نحن بصدد دوره او
بويضه كل شهر اما الرجل فينتج ملايين
الملايين من الحيوانات يوميا اذا تحدثنا
عن اساليب منع الحمل او يعني
توقف الحمل عند الرجل او توقف الاخصاب عند
الرجل فكان الرجل قديما يميل الى شيئين
اما العزل اللي هو يقذف السائل المنوي
خارج الرحم واما ان يميل الى العزل
الموضعي عند المراه بوضع عازل او ما يسمى
بالكاوتشوك او اللوب او او اي شيء من هذا
يمكن هذه الاشياء الواقي الذكري نعم هذه
اشياء بسيطه ومعقده لكن اللجوء الى
الاستروجين حضرتك ده اثاره مدمره ده احنا
عملنا تجارب هنا في الجامعات على بعض
المتطوعين لان الاستروجين بيسقط اللحيه
والشارب ويكبر حجم الثدي عند الرجل ويغير
صوته ده مش ده مش هيبقى راجل
للمنع الحبل عند الرجال
واكيد كل الرجال بخافوا يكون فيه رده فعل
بس هيطلع على رديت الفعل تبع حبوب او حكم
منع الحبل عند الرجال بنلاقيها انه نفس
رديت الفعل عند النساء يعني الاعراض اعراض
الجانبيه هي ذاتها يعني مثلا بياخد الوزن
بصير فيه اللي بده يعني
هي ذاتها عندها او وجع راسها رديت الفعل
ولا عادات الجانبيه هي ذاتها
التي تحدثوا عنه ربما دكتور جوده من
القاهره يعني بالنسبه الى دراسات التي
اجريت هنا ومتى
الاستروجين اكيد
رجل امراه
عم نوقف بس الفبركه تبع الخلايا طيب دعونا
نذهب معا الى عده عواصم عربيه لنتعرف اكثر
على راي المواطنات والمواطنين سالنا بعيدا
عن الواقي الذكري هل تقبل او تقبلين
استخدام وسائل منع حمل اخرى للرجال كيف
اتت الاجابات نستمع معا
[موسيقى]
من ربع المستحيلات حد يعمل حاجه زي كده
كرجال يعني انما كسيدات ممكن لا طبعا مش
ممكن اخدها لا لا لا هديه معروفه بس
للستات فقط لكن الرجاله لا يعني للرجال او
امر جديد احنا لسه سامعينه واحد ان العالم
اعتقد هستعمل الحبوب لان جوزي راح تكون
مضره
الرجال شلون استخدم هاي هاي شي تخصص بس
للنساء فقط ماكو هالشي يعني معين خلينا
نستخدم هذا الشيء يجوز للنساء اوكي وهذا
الامور
يناقضه والدين الاسلامي ويرفضه الدين
الاسلامي العقيد القذافيره في مقاله قال
المراه
هو الرجل يلد
نعرف وحده على الاقل
اللي هي ربط القنوات وعندي واحد صاحبي
عملها
[موسيقى]
عامه للسيدات فقط لو ما ينفعش ياكل حاجه
زي كده لا طبعا انا اخد منع الحمله كان
جوزي طبعا لا لا طبعا ما ياخدهاش لان احنا
اتعودنا ان احنا ناخذ راجل راجل فما مساء
المانع للمسافه ما زاد وسائل منع حمل
للرجال كما مثلا لكن نسمع نفهم وسائل
الرجال ما نخليش شريك حياتي يستعملها
على خاطر
في وسائل المناعه علاش
نعملو فيه للرجال احنا نسايز
لتونس معك سيد حازم الشيخاوي يعني لماذا
برايك من اين ياتي هذا الرفض رفض هذه
الوسائل من اين ياتي تحدث منذ قليل دكتور
جوده وهو يعبر يعبر ربما عن الراي واسع
ايضا في الشارع العربي بالمساله الحفاظ
على النسل وهذا البعد الديني هل هناك
ابعاد اخرى غير هذا البعد برايك تؤدي الى
رفض وسائل منع الحمل للرجال
طبعا تقريبا هذه الحجج التي استمعنا اليها
هي حجج عاطفيه وحجاج شعبيه جدا هي حجج
اقرب منها الى الاستهلاك وقد تحتوي على
الكثير من المغالطات لان المجتمع هو يسير
وفقا لتصورات وتمثلات معينه اهمها وما
استمعنا اليه تقريبا في مقاله الدكتور
جوده وهو خطاب نوع من خطابات الوصايه هي
وصايه على اجساد الافراد مهما كانوا هؤلاء
الافراد نساء او رجالا اي اننا نعطي
للمواطنين والمواطنات اوامر بان ناخذ هذه
بان ناخذ هذه الوسائل او لا ناخذها وهنالك
بطبيعه الحال مستوى اخر هو مستوى الرؤيه
الابويه في التعامل مع مثل هذه المسائل
عندما سمعنا الى الشهادات الحيه من مختلف
تقريبا شوارع العالم العربي وجدنا ان
هنالك نوع من التاثيم في علاقه
استهلاك الرجال او اخذهم لهذه الماده التي
هي ليست متوفره الى حد الان في وهذا معطى
مهم اي ان هنالك رفض ما قبل لهذه المساله
لاننا ببساطه نمارس في نوع من الهيمنه
تؤخرها قم باختيار يبدو ان هذا ما يؤخر
وصولها الى السوق دكتور سيكون لنا معلومه
واكمل معك حازم تفضل دكتور بمساله حبوب
منع الحمل للرجال لماذا تاخرت
كذا سبب من بين الاسباب هي
لبراطوريه اللي بيفبرك الحبوب اكيد عم
بيفبري المختبرات المختبره لتصنعها عم
تصنعها تتبعها
خايفين كتير ما تنباع لان خيفانين ان
الرجال ما ياخذوا
النسوان يرفضوا رجال يخدوا حبوب لسبب بسيط
اذا الرجال نسع ما اخذ الحبل او
اذا هو نسي ياخذ طريقه منع الحبل ما هي
اللي راح يكون عندها حبل مش هو يعني بين
خوف الرجال وبين خوف النساء اللي ما
الاشاره اليوم انه فقط يعني 27% من الرجال
في العالم يعني هذه الدراسات اليوم يلجاون
هم الى وسائل منع الحمل يعني
منخفض جدا تفضل تفضل كمل استاذ حازم اعود
اليك دكتور تفضل طبعا الى زينب الاستاذ
جلباب هنالك بطبيعه الحال بهذا المعطى
الاقتصادي المهم لانه لو نعود الى ثانويه
الخمسينات والستينات سنلاحظ ان ما يسمى
بالوسائل الهرمونيه لمنع الحمل اتجهت
اساسا لطبقات المهمشه والطبقات الفقيره
وطبقات المقصيه على اساس العرق او الهامش
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ثم انتشر
الامر شيئا فشيئا في في بقيه انحاء العالم
اذا اليوم المساله هي مرتبطه ايضا بهذا
المعطي بمعطى الاستهلاك وبمعطه
بمعطى تجاري وبمعطى البيع
وايضا مساله اخرى الى ان هنالك تقديس
لسوره اجساد الرجال لو امكن التعبير بهذا
المعنى لان جسد الرجال من المفترض انه لا
يتم المساس به لا يتم التقليل من شانه
ونحن نعلم ان الرؤيه العلاقات الحميميه
والعلاقات الجنسيه بشكل واسع هي رؤيه يعني
نوعا ما نقولها بالفرنسيه
انها تتعلق بنوع من
به الرجال
نعم وهذه وهذه وهذه العلاقه هي هي تحمل
علاقه هيمنه رمزيه اذا ليس ليس من المفترض
ان مس بارجال باجساد الرجال وفي المخيل
العام في العالم العربي تقريبا على الاقل
اتحدث على تونس مساله المتعه تغيب تماما
عندما يتعلق الامر بمتعه النساء وبمتعه
الرجال نحن دائما ما نفضل متعه الرجال على
متعه النساء وسبب الاخر بطبيعه الحال ان
يجب ان يكون الحب حبوب لتحفيز لتحفيز
المتعه لدى الرجال يعني ولا توجد لدى
النساء حتى الان طيب اريد ان اسال من
القاهره الدكتور جوده دكتور جوده اريد ان
اسالك اليوم اذا ما تم التوصل الى حبوب
منع حمل للرجال كما هي الحال اليوم للنساء
باطار تنظيم الاسره انا لا اتحدث عن
العلاقات الاخرى تنظيم الاسره هناك حبوب
للنساء وللرجال وقيل وتم تاكيد ان هذه
الحبوب يعني اثارها الجانبيه لا تتخطى
الاثار الاخرى لحبوب النسائيه
لماذا سيبقى الخوف من تناول هذه هذه
الحبوب
هو بس انا عايز اقول بس كلام علم يرضي
ربنا اولا انا حاسس على الدكتوراه في
الفسيولوجيا انا الطبيب خليه كليه طب واخد
دبلوم باطنه يعني استاذ طبيب اقول لك عليه
انه مساله ربنا يخليك حبوب منع الحمل لها
اضرار كثيره للنساء ليه بقى لانها
كارثينوجينك يعني مسببه للسرطان وبعدين
بتعمل لنا اورام رحمه اورام ثدي وهشاشه
عظام وبتعرضها للتراب هرموني والسكر وسقوط
الشعر وفساد الجلد يعني انت كل بلاد
العالم المتقدم
كلها لا انت فقط مع الوسائل الطبيعيه
يعني عن برافو عليك نعم انا انا احذر احذر
اي امراه في العالم من الوسائل الهرمونيه
ولا زرعه تحت الجلد ولا حقن منع الحمل
اي شيء دكتور يعني اليوم حابه
قد درسنا في الاف اسمعيني بعد اذنك هي
الاف الدراسات طلعت على انها ضاره بالصح
وبتعمل سرطان وبتعمل سكر وهشاشه عظام بتوع
الشعر وبتخلي الانثى عايزه تكره جوزها
وتقتله فاللي احنا عاوزين فيه بدائل اخرى
اه في بدايل احنا عندنا 13 وسيله لمنع
الحمل فانا النهارده مش جاي بعد 2023 عن
حبوب ثبت فشلها فاللي انا عايز اقوله ان
الهرمونات كان لها وقتها خلاص هللنا
وطبلنا زمان دلوقتي ما فيش حد هيطبل منع
الحمل الا اذا كانت معلومات متخلفه اللي
انا عايز اقول مهم جدا قالوا حبوب منع
الحمل تناسب البنات من سن 15 اخرنا 35 سنه
ممنوع عندنا واحده بعد 35 سنه تاخذ حبوب
منع حمل او لصقه تحت الجلد او حقن مانع
حمل اللي بيعمل كده عندنا بيتحاكم الكلام
ده واضح
جسم المراه
اخرنا ايوه يا فندم عندنا اخرنا في حبوب
منع الحمل وحقن منع الحمل واقراص منع
الحمل وكبسولات منع الحمل 35 سنه
ده انا اسمع راي السيده الوحيده معنا قبل
ان اعود اليك الدكتور جلباب صبا ما رايك
بهذا النقاش الدائري يعني
الاستنتاجات التي ربما قد تبدر او تاتي
الى ذهنك
انا اريد ان اتحدث اولا عن
الاسره يجب ان يكون لديها الخيارات في
تحديد النسل يجب ان تكون الخيارات متعدده
المراه يعني بحكم انه هي بالمجتمعات عنا
هي دوره النمطي هو الانجاب بمعظم الرجال
يعتقدون ان المراه هي للانجاب فقط فيجب
عليها ان تكون حره في جسدها عليها لها
سلطه في التحكم في شرزتها في متى ستلد في
متى لا يجب ان تتشارك هذا الشيء مع الرجل
يجب ان يتحدث الرجل معها حول مثلا كيف
[موسيقى]
نمتنع عن انجاب الاطفال في هذه الفتره
لاسباب متعدده يجب ان يحصل تواصل بين
الطرفين الى جانب فكره انه كما قال
الدكتور انه التاثير الحبوب منع الحمل على
النساء هي سيئه جدا
فيمكن يعني لماذا نتخيل ان يمكن للمراه ان
تاخذ هذه الحبوب ولكن لا يمكن للرجل تقاسم
الذهني ربما الاكتئاب تقاسم ما يسمى
بالعبئ الذهني اليوم يعني لماذا هذا العب
سيقع على عاتق المراه اذا اختر نعم تفضلي
الى جانب ان الرجل في بعض المجتمعات عند
الاثر عندما يحصل حمل يلوم المراه يعني
تعتبر انه انت اخذتي حبوب منع الحمل ماذا
حصل يعني انت المسؤوله الوحيده عن هذا هذه
العمليه التي فشلت كما كما
بعض الاطفال غلطه يمكن
غلطه المراه
بالطبع هو
يلقي بالله عليها بشكل بشكل مباشر فلذلك
يجب ان يكون عليها فكره انه هي يكون في
خيارات متعدده امامه وتكون حره
يعني من هنا الحديث عن وسائل المنع الحمل
للرجال يعني لماذا في الخيارات طيب قبل ان
نذهب الى حازم تفضل دكتور جلبر ولديك ما
تقول دكتور جوده بالقاهره
اول طريقه منع الحمل معروفه بتاريخ
الانسانيه كانت بمصر من 45 سنه للفراعنه
اخترعوا خلاط
بعسل مع اكاسيا مع اشرف بدي انحط كان بعد
يعني كانت طبيعيه ثاني ملاحظه في
عم ننبش على طريقه طبيعيه لمنع الحمل عند
الرجال وعند النساء في طريقه طبيعيه وصلت
على امريكا من سنتين عند النساء بلا
هرمونات عند الرجال صار في كذا عشبه
جربناها المشكله بالطريقه الطبيعيه انه
رديت الفعل اوقات اقوى من الهرمونات مثلا
في عشبه صينيه جربناها كانت كان مفعولها
كتير منيحه عن منع الحمل عن الرجال بسنتين
بالميه من الحالات كان منع الحمل نهائي
وما كان فيه
يعني طيب برايك اليوم لماذا يربط الرجل
هناك الكثير من يعني مما قرانا كثير من
الرجال يقولون في حال مثلا قمنا بعمليه
تعقيم او اخذنا وسائل من حمل للرجال لن
نقذف مجددا او لن يخرج منا حيوانات منويه
مجددا من اين اتت هذه الافكار هيدي
الافكار قديمه كتير
مثل الخليط
نفساني انه اذا ما في
يجيب اولاد معناتها مني قوي جنسيه هيدا
الخريطه كتير كتير قديم
وهيدا خطا كبير لان
الطريقه للجسم بيشتغل فيها تيكون في حبل
هي طريقه تاني للعلاقات الجنسيه يعني
الاورمونات هن ذاتها بس
نعمل عمليه تيكون منع الحمل ما بينقزها
ابدا ما بينقذى ابدا ابدا
طريقه علاقه الجنسيه
يعني ما في خطر ابدا لا يؤثر ابدا على
العكس بالعكس ساعه الي بحس الرجال حاله
انه
ما راح يصير في حمل بلا ما يكون هو
صحيه دعونا قبل ان نعود الى نقاشنا دعونا
نستمع الى شهاده وهو صحافي فرنسي قام
باجراء تحقيق مطول عن وسائل منع الحمل
للرجال كما جربها على نفسه بعد ان اوقفت
حبيبته استخدام حبوب منع الحمل بسبب
تاثيرها السلبي على صحتها يعني يشرح لنا
في المقطع التالي احدى وسائل منع الحمل
للرجال المتوفره في فرنسا وهي السروال
الداخلي الحراري
احضرت وسيله منع حمل حراريه سروال داخلي
مانع للحمل
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه هو لا يباع في الصيدليات او في
المتاجر هذا يعني ان الرجل الذي يستعمل
هذه الوسيله مجبر على خياطه سرواله
الداخلي هذا انا شخصيا لا اجيد الخياطه
فكما تشاهدون هذان الخيطان غير متساويان
فشلته قليلا ولكن النتيجه كانت ايجابيه
لماذا اريكم هذا التبان قد يبدو غريبا فهو
يشبه السروال الداخلي لذا الخيط الواحد
يتم ارتداؤه تحت الملابس الداخليه يمكنكم
ارتداؤه لوحده ولكن لا انصحكم بذلك لانه
غير مثير بتاتا
هنا نرى الحلقه مع رباط لغلقها يدرج العضو
الذكري بداخلها
ثم نمرر شلدتها كيس الخصيتين بالطبع لا
نضع الخصيتين بالكامل بعد ذلك سيتم الضغط
عليهما وستشعر الخصيتين بالضيق وبالتالي
ستصعدني الى الاعلى ولهذا تسمى هذه
الوسيله بطريقه تعليق الخصيتين اذا
ستتواجد للخصيهان هنا على الجانبين
الخصيتين الى الاعلى سيجعلهما اكثر دفئا
بسبب حراره الجسم ارتداء هذا السروال
الداخلي 15 ساعه يوميا دون اللجوء
للهرمونات ولمده ثلاثه اشهر متواصله
يجعلنا نحصل على وسيله منع حمل للرجال لان
دوره انتاج الحيوانات المنويه مدتها 75
يوما
اذا يجب الانتظار ثلاثه اشهر لمعرفه مدى
نجاعه وسيله منع الحمل هذه بعد القيام
باختبارات الدم والفحوصات الطبيه اللازمه
في الواقع لا توجد متابعه طبيه معينه رغم
معرفتنا بانها وسيله فعاله لكنها في
الحقيقه لم تمر بكل اليات التحقق العلميه
ليتم تعميمها على نطاق واسع اذا ننصح من
يريده اتباع هذه الطريقه ان يفعل ذلك ولكن
مع استشاره طبيه اي بمراقبته ومتابعه
مجموعه من الاطباء وذلك عبر اجراء اختبار
للحيوانات المنويه للتاكد من انخفاض
اعدادها وبالتالي من نجاحه وسيله منع
الحمل هذه
[موسيقى]
قبل ان اتحدث اكثر عن السروال الحراري
ساذهب اعود الى تونس مع استاذ حازم تفضل
كنت تريد ان تعلق ان تقول قبل شيئا ما قبل
ان ينقطع الخط معك تفضل
نعم في الحقيقه هنالك ايضا بعض اخر
اجتماعي في هذه المساله فيما يتعلق اليوم
بهذه الوسائل لمنع الحمد وهي مساله من
سيقوم برعايه من او بادوار الرعايه داخل
المنازل وداخل وداخل ما يسمى بالعائله او
بمؤسسه العائله وهو امر مهم ان نشير اليه
لان ببساطه اليوم نحن نوكل مهمه الرعايه
الكامله للنساء لاجساد النساء ولطاقات
النساء داخل المنازل لذلك نحن نعتبر ان
عمليه ما قبل انجاب الاطفال بما هي عمليه
حمل وبما هي مؤسسه زواج ايضا هي مساله يجب
ان ترمى على عاتق النساء مباشره ولا يجب
ان نذكر ابدا اجساد الرجال طبعا العالم
تغيره مع ما قدمته الحركات النسويه وهنا
يمكن ان اعود الى مساله ان الحركات
النسويه جانب منها في سنوات الخمسينات
طالبنا عديد المسويات في العالم تقريبا
بخلق وسائل لمنع الحمل لقطع مع هذه
الادوار مع ما يسمى الرعايه لكن اليوم
هنالك مراجعات كبرى في الحركات المتاخره
لحركات النسويه المتاخره لانها فعلا هي
تقدم اليوم عديد من النتائج التي تضر
باجساد النساء مثل القلق النفسي ومثل
الامراض ونتائج السلبيه بطبيعه الحال لكن
هذا لا يعني اننا نحن نذهب واريد فقط ننهي
بهذه الكلمه نحن لا نريد الذهاب نحو منع
وسائل الحمل بشكل نهائي لكن من المهم ان
نفكر فيما يضمن سلامه الاجساد وما يضمن
البعض
الادويه انه
الذي بطبيعه بطبيعه الحال للنساء والرجال
دعني اسالك الحجاج القوانين في هذا الامر
تفضل تفضل باختصار
هذه الكلمه اذا الذهاب نحو ان نفتح وفق
اخذ وسائل صحيه ووسائل الوقايه ووسائل لا
يمكن ان تضر بالاجساد للنساء والرجال
سيعزز مفهوم المساواه وسيحزز مفهوم
الانصاف بين مختلف التعبيرات الجندريه بين
مختلف اشكال التواجد لاننا في النهايه نحن
لا نتعامل بمنطق الوصايه نحن نريد ان نترك
الاختيار للافراد ان يكون هنالك اختيار
مستنير للافراد في اخذ قراراتهم وقراراتهم
وفي تكويرا الى عدمها ومؤسس الزواج بعد ان
لديهم ولديهن طبعا كل المعلومات الصحيحه
حول حول هذه الوسائل اريد ان اسال دكتور
جوده قبل ان اعود الى اليك دكتور جلباب
ومن ثم صبا دكتور جوده يعني اليوم هناك
كما استمعت الى ما يسمى بالسروال الحراري
السروال الحراري هو يعني ما في لا هرمون
ولا ولا دواء ولا من يحزنون هل تعتبر ان
ممكن ان يكون هذا يعني ربما حل
لتقليص عبء تحمل مسؤوليه الحمل على النساء
فقط طريقه الحراره كمان على الحمل الدكتور
جوده ساعود اليك دكتور
تعود اليك اتفضل دكتور جوده ساعود اليك
دكتور مو مشكله يعني كان زمان في مبدا في
التجاره بيقول لك ليه تدفع اكتر ما دام
ممكن تدفع اقل انا دلوقتي عندي وسائل امنه
وبسيطه ورخيصه وامنه بالنسبه للمراه
بتستعملك سواء كان لوب او سواء في مصر 13
وسيله لمنع الحمل بسيطه تتناسب مع ظروف اي
امراه
ولا تمثل مشكله
للرجل سيدي يعني انت اليوم تقول للمراه
للمراه للمراه وال انا دلوقتي عندي عندي
المراه فتره الخصوبه بتاعتها ما بتكملش 30
سنه ده كل الخصوبه من 15 45 كلها 30 سنه
الراجل 50 سنه في دول كثيره من العالم
يجب ان نحترم خيارات الناس هذا واقع متوسط
سن بعد اذنك ده متوسط سن الانجاب عندنا من
سن 15 ل 45 سنه اذا الاخصاب في العالم كله
عند المراه 30 هنقول 40 في بعض الدول في
عندنا رجال لغايه 80 و90 سنه ربنا مدي له
الصحه وبيشتغل يعني يقدر يتزوج امراه
طبعا والد اطفال بعمر يعني هذا الرجل
الطاقه القوه مصدر العزه مصدر السند الظهر
لولاده لزوجاته والكذا والكذا انا اريد
اليوم ان اجعله فارس تجارب مثل تتحدث عن
مصر سؤال لك اليوم في مصر هناك حواله 38%
من المجتمع اليوم سيدات هن المعيلات في
العائلات يعني هن السند لعائلتهن اليوم
كيف تطلب من هذه السيده كيف تطلب من هذه
السيده ان تتحمل هي عبء عدم الحمل في حال
كان هناك ضروره لعدم الحمل وتقول ان الرجل
يعني هو القوه والسند
ما دامت هي العاقل هي مش مطلوب منها حمل
اذا كانت هي تعول اسره يبقى يا اما مطلقه
او ارمله يعني هي دلوقتي بقت عاقل انطبق
عليها شروط الرجال اذا هي عاقل الاسره لا
هي هتحمل لانها مطلقه واما ارمله طيب خلاص
خرجت من الدائره
اسمح لي سيدي ولكن يعني ربما هذا هذا ما
تتفضل به هذا يظلم الكثير من السيدات ربما
هناك سيدات معيلات ومتزوجات لان ازواجهن
عاطلين عن العمل مثلا ساسال دكتور دكتور
جلباب هنا في الاستوديو عن مساله السروال
الحراري لنعود الى سروال الحراري تقول
هناك اقبال كبير عليه لماذا هنا لان
الطريقه معتبره طبيعيه ما في هرمونات ما
في ادويه بس منا طبيعيه ميه بالميه لان
حراره الخصايا لازم على طول تكون خصيتين
على طول لازم تكون درجتين او ثلاث درجات
تحت تحت حراره الجسم يعني لازم تكون
34 35 درجه حراره الجسم
مشان هيك الاشخاص يلي بيشتغلوا بمطارح
كثير فيها حراره مثلا افران معامل فيها
حراره كتير بيكون عندهم مشاكل تيجي
الطريقه بتقول اوكي راح نحط الحراره بنفس
حراره الجسم
منخفف فبركه الخليج
والتصاقيهما بجسد
المشكله اللي عنا اياه هي مشكلتين
بهالطريقه اول مشكله شو بصير اذا هالشخص
يلبسها الوقت المحدد والو لازم يكون في
ساعه بالنهار كل يوم كل يوم كل يوم شو
بيصير هلا بدي يرجع يبلش عن جديد ثلاثه
اشهر واخطر ما بنعرف اذا هالطريقه بعد
لهلا ما بنعرف هي بتعلي
السرطان لان بنعرف انه عند الولاد بتكون
الحراره اعلى بيكون في ريسك لسرطان اذا
يعني الدراسات لم تكتمل حول هذه الطريقه
حتى الان وبالتالي طيب دعني اذهب الى صبا
صبا اريد ان اسالك اليوم انت كسيده وكسيده
نسويه في مساله منع الحمل بشكل عام ووسائل
منع الحمل برايك ما الذي يحقق لك
المساواه مع شريكك في هذه المساله
ان يكون لي حريه الاختيار ان يكون لي
ولشريك حريه الاختيار في هذه المساله يعني
عندما نكون سنكون اسره يجب ان يكون ان
يعلم بتفاصيل العمليه الانجابيه بعد
الرجال لا يعلمون شيئا كما قال الدكتور من
تونس اعتقد ان بعض الرجال يعتقدون ان
ممارسه الجنس هنا تنتهي يعني مهمتهم فتصبح
المهمه هي مهمه المراه فقط من خلال الحمل
الانجاب الرعايه وكافه
التفاصيل التي تاتي بعد بعد ذلك
فالفكره التي تحقق لي المساواه مع الرجل
هي حريه الاختيار لي وللرجل الوسائل يجب
ان تكون متاحه
ولشريكي يجب ان يكون لي سهوله الوصول الى
هذه الهذا دون اي ضغوطات معينه ويجب ان
نكون هناك توعيه يعني يجب ان نعرف
انا وشريكي عن المخاطر يجب ان تكون
المعلومات هي متاحه بسهوله في في الاسواق
الاطباء الحصول عليها والحصول على الوسائل
اللازمه طيب حازم اريد ان اسالك يعني في
مساله الثقه اليوم تحدثت عن راي النسويات
يعني تغير راي التيارات النسويه بمساله
حبوب منع الحمل لدى النساء مع مر الزمن
اليوم يعني برايك لماذا لا يشعر الرجل حتى
في الدول يعني المتقدمه فعليا والتي وصلت
فيها المراه الى يعني الى حقوقها بشكل
اكبر لماذا لا يشعر الرجل بالمسؤوليه هل
لانه فقط لا يحمل
طبعا المساله لديها ابعاد متعدده اهمها
ربما في هذا الاطار هو البعد التاريخي لان
رواسب المجتمعات الابويه وروايات
المجتمعات الذكوريه في كافه انحاء العالم
متجذره في التاريخ تعود الى قرون تعود الى
حضارات قديمه وقديمه جدا يمكن ان نذكر
الحضاره الاغريقيه والحضاره المصريه والى
غيرها من الحضارات التي مرت على التاريخ
لذلك من الصعب جدا مع موجات التغيير
الحقوقي في العالم ان نصل الى مبدا
المساواه التامه بين كافه المواطنات
والمواطنين ولاحظي سيدتي هنا انني استعمل
كلمه المواطنات والمواطنين لانهم من العيب
ان نعتبر اليوم اجساد النساء واجساد
الرجال بمثل الالات التي يجب ان نضغط على
الازرار لكي تقوم بعمل معين لان اليوم في
حقيقه الامر في هذه الظرفيه التي نعيشها
في ظرفيه العولمه في ظرفيه هذا الاقتصاد
المفتوح تقريبا في كافه انحاء العالم الذي
اضاف بعض النقاط ممكن الايجابيه لكن اضاف
عديد النقاط السلبيه لم لم تعد هنالك حدود
اقتصاديه واضحه مثلا الدكتور جوده اثار
الى ان اثار مساله ان النساء لا يعمل لكن
النساء داخل البيوت يعمل ويعمل ما يقارب
14 ساعه كل يوم في تقديم خدمات للاطفال
والكهول والى غيرهم من ذلك لذلك نحن اليوم
لدينا هذه وفي الطبخ وفي الرعايه وفي
التنظيف وان صوره المراه المثاليه هي سوره
المراه التي يجب ان تقوم برعايه منزلها
وربما بالاشتغال خارج المنزل ايضا وبتقسيم
ادوار العمل وان نجعل بعض
الاعمال الاعمال انثويه بحته وان نرفع
الطابع الاختلاط عنها وهذا خطيره اليوم
لانه يهدد كل القيم
الكونيه التي يمكن ان توجد من بينها
المساواه والانصاف بين الجميع بطبيعه
الحال وايضا لان هنالك نظام امتيازات
يتمتع يتمتع بها الرجال في كافه انحاء
العالم ليس من السهل ان ان يتم التخلي
عنها بسهوله الراحه هل يمكن فقط ان تختصر
فكرتك لو سمحت انتهى الوقت
فقط اقول انني هذا نظام الامتيازات في
العالم هو يمنع بطبيعه الحال الرجال من ان
يقوموا بالتخلي عن عن كل هذه كل الاساليب
الراحه والرفاه نوعا ما داخل المجتمعات
الابويه والذكوريه ذلك المساله صعبه ويجب
ان ربما ان نشتغل عليها في عديد المجالات
مثل التعليم والصحه والتوعيه في علاقه
بهذه المسائل وبعلاقه بالصحه اساسا
ساختم معك برايك هل يمكن ان نصل يوما ما
الى المساواه في مساله تناول وسائل منع
الحمل لا داعي بين الرجال انه نعم فينا
ناصر وبعتقد انه مش راح تكون بالهرمونات
راح نلاقي طريقه غير بعدين عندي فكره راح
تغير الحاله لبعدين في اطباء نساء اكثر
اليوم من قبل الاطباء الرجال طوروا الطرق
لضد ضعف الجنسي عند الرجال وما طوروا طرق
ههه بالتالي انت بالنسبه اليك اليوم
مشاركه النساء في المجال الطبي بشكل اكبر
مجال الطبي بشكل اكبر من قبل بعتقد رح
يغير اشياء كثيره من ناحيه طرق منع الحمل
وغير غير اشياء
شكرا لك دكتور شكرا لكل الضيوف والضيفات
النقاش الفلك الممنوع لا نهايه لها نتركه
لك ولك حريه التفكير وحريه الاختيار
تابعونا دائما على شاشه
الدوليه تحياتي
[موسيقى]